>> Tucker: IN A NEW
ADVERTISEMENT, THE NRA WARNS
LEFT WING JOURNALISTS THAT TIME
IS RUNNING OUT FOR THEM.
HERE IT IS.
>> TO EVERY LYING MEMBER OF THE
MEDIA, TO EVERY HOLLYWOOD PHONY,
TO THE ROLE MODEL ATHLETES THAT
USE THEIR FREE SPEECH TO
UNDERMINE WHAT OUR FLAG REGULAR
SENTS, TO THE POLITICIANS THAT
WOULD RATHER WATCH AMERICAN BURN
THAN TO LOSE THEIR OWN NATIONAL
POWER, TO THE LATE NIGHT HOSTS
WHO THINK THEIR OPINIONS ARE THE
ONLY ONES THAT MATTER, TO THE
MORNING JOS, THE MIKAS, TO THOSE
THAT STAIN HONEST REPORTING WITH
PARTISANSHIP, TO THOSE THAT
BRING BIAS AND PROPAGANDA, YOUR
TIME IS RUNNING OUT.
>> THAT'S DANA LASH.
IN THE AD SHE SPEAKS FOR THE
NRA.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: SO YOU ARE BEING
CRITICIZED FOR INCITING VIOLENCE
BY SAYING "TIME IS UP."
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> THAT'S A PLAY ON THE TIMES UP
MOVEMENT, THE HOLLYWOOD
PROGRESSION
PROGRESSIO
PROGRESSION.
AT THE VERY END OF THAT VIDEO,
IT WAS AN ANNOUNCEMENT FOR A
PROGRAM THAT I'M DOING FOR NRA
TV.
FREE PEOPLE HAVE THE THE RIGHT
TO HOLD ACCOUNTABLE AND FACT
CHECK THE PRESS.
TO THOSE IN THE MEDIA AND THOSE
IN HOLLYWOOD THAT ARE LYING, YES
THIS IS AN INDICTMENT OF YOU.
THE PROGRAM FOR NRA TV WHICH
LAUNCHES AT THE END OF THE MONTH
IS FOCUSING ON MEDIA MALPRACTICE
AND HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE,
WHICH WE HAVE SEEN TONS OF
PARTICULARLY IN THE PAST YEAR.
>> Tucker: WHERE DO YOU THINK
THAT COMES FROM?
>> I THINK IT'S JUST HONESTLY --
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT DON'T UNDERSTAND MIDDLE
AMERICA.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE SECOND
AMENDMENT PRACTITIONERS.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE.
I WAS FED UP WITH MAINSTREAM
MEDIA, LEGACY MEDIA AND THE
MALPRACTICE THEREOF.
WE SAW HOW THEY IMPUGNED THE
CHARACTERS OF THOSE PEOPLE, THE
MEMBERS OF THE TEA PARTY.
THEY IGNORE MALIGNED
CONSERVATIVE WOMEN.
THEY IGNORE GAY CONSERVATIVES.
THEY BASH GOOD PEOPLE IN
FLY-OVER NATION THAT WERE GOOD
ENOUGH TO VOTE FOR THE CLINTONS
FOR HOW MANY YEAR.
AND THEY TURN AROUND AND VOTE
FOR TRUMP, THOSE PEOPLE ARE
BIGOTS AND RACISTS.
WE'VE WATCHED MEDIA MALIGN SO
MANY GOOD AMERICANS AND REPORT
ONE SIDE OF THE STORY.
LOOK AT EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED
WITH PARKLAND.